you specifically yourself i mean um
have what 1.2 million twitter followers
right yeah and what am i what's my
what's my political affiliation your
critical affiliation right where did you
talk about that right um yeah i mean i
don't think you are exactly what you
claim you are
what am i um you know i would say you're
pretty much a conservative what makes me
conservative what makes you uh a liberal
uh well traditional liberals in this
country uh specifically social liberal
uh is whereas i've always been voted for
obama in 2008. a lot of people voted for
obama in 2008 and then moved over to
trump we've established that so i voted
for trump in 2020 yeah there you go
right so uh traditional liberals all
those liberals who voted for trump nine
million in this country mm-hmm that's
right considering them liberal and
substantially more uh donald trump is
talking about democrats not liberals no
they're liberal uh donald trump is a new
york a new york liberal
like donald trump unfurled an lgbt flag
on the rnc stage
and got republicans to clap for it oh
sure okay so uh i'm pro-choice uh well
we could talk about that yeah i'm
pro-progressive tax uh i'm pro-green new
deal
are you
oh yes really absolutely really i don't
think you watch the show i know i have
watched the show i've seen you
completely come out and get really mad
at uh alexandria ocasio-cortez for sure
yeah
deal do you mean like free college for
black people
what did you read no i did but that's
that that's what bothers you uh what
bothers me is that when i advocate for
environmental policy having worked for
several environments and i don't think
and also i don't think the policy says
free college for black people no no it's
it's it's free college it's free health
care for marginalized and oppressed
communities
what does that have to do with wind
turbines what are you talking about is
everything to do with the environmental
situation we're going to be in no that's
race policy no it's not who do you what
do you think happens when climate change
affects the united states of america who
do you think is going to be the most
affected by it who's not going to be
able like ben shapiro said who's not
going to be able to just get up sell
their house that's going sailing out to
the sea and going underwater like ben
shapiro said um
who's going to be able to uh easily
get themselves out of a situation that
sees their neighborhood getting flooded
their neighbor their you know
they're going to lose what they
currently have it's not going to be the
wealthy it's not going to be people who
are in comfortable situations we just
get up and move it's going to be people
who don't have means
so when we lift people out of poverty
we'll be able to more uh better address
climate change issues when they arise
just just to go back real quick i did
find the data showing that youtube
overwhelmingly uh sends content to the
left um and not the right so that you
have to send this to me because this
goes against every piece of research
i've ever read about youtube
i i will i will say outright one of the
challenges with any kind of political
debate is that you're going to
everyone's going to find their sources
you know whatever well where's your
source from this is firstmonday.org this
is an academic named mark ledwich who
worked with a series of other academics
they they've mapped out look they got me
as anti-sjw here with sargon of akkad
and what they did was they they grouped
everything by a whole bunch of different
um channels there's like white
identitarian there's partisan right
there's conspiracy there's social
justice there's center left mainstream
media and then they created parents for
what typically
socially falls into a left or right
category and then they created
this uh recommendation uh trend map
showing you
partisan left content typically
recommends partisan left content
center content typically recommends
partisan i'm sorry typically recommend
center content however when we're
talking about who's getting recommended
the most
from the center you're more likely twice
or three times as likely to get partisan
left content than partisan right content
so if you what do they consider
left-wing content uh socialist social
justice what what partisan left what is
that like what what are we talking about
here though because there's right
wingers and there's all sorts of people
who view nbc and cnn and other
corporates that's that's
mainstream media okay well that's center
left mainstream media okay
center slash left mainstream oh it's its
own category is what you're so so they
mean like
your tv networks the news they report
and like overwhelmingly anti-trump for
instance uh comedy specials and things
like that if you go on youtube and you
watch jimmy kimmel you are
the most likely to just see more jimmy
kimmel but when it comes to the
political direction new information
flows as you can see from mark
lightwitch's research and there's a
couple other researchers sorry i'm not
reading their names uh you are i mean it
looks like
three or four to one you're more likely
to get partisan left-wing content than
right-wing content well that goes you're
also every research advocate is one for
example now check this out check it out
also if you are watching partisan
right-wing content you are more likely
to be recommended center or mainstream
content than if you were on the left
in for the same number it's it seems
somewhat comparable but considering the
partisan left receives 99.5 million
daily impressions to the partisan right
68.6 that's a disproportionate amount of
recommendations in favor of partisan
left all right well i need to see that
study in front of me because i could
easily just pull up another one that
just says you know more than 330 000
videos and nearly 350 youtube channels
were analyzed and manually classified uh
labeled as either media or what we think
of as factual news alt light
intellectual dark red or alt-right and
then it found that
uh youtube's algorithm funnels people to
alt-right videos but by by how much i
mean it does that's a fact statement
it absolutely does now twitter um
diminished alt-right channels and banned
most of them
they cut them all off from the
recommendation algorithm so the time
period in which you did that uh that
study would be important but also yeah
absolutely youtube recommends everything
youtube does recommend alt-right content
for sure they banned a lot of it uh the
issue is and in in large amounts like
if a regular person goes on youtube and
watches jimmy kimmel are they more
likely to fall into a left or right wing
rabbit hole the data shows the left
all right yeah i mean that's that
study's true but but i mean look look
but i mean how often is someone who's
watching jimmy kimmel going and looking
for more political videos i'm assuming
they're going to be looking for
entertainment content right which is why
the overwhelming majority so so if you
look at the left
on this chart for those that are
watching can you pull it up
so if you look on the left you can see
there's a purple bar on the right is
another purple bar
the purple going straight across
that represents the overwhelming
majority of people who watch center or
left mainstream media will only be
recommended center or left mainstream
media when you look on the left you see
this this line going down
that represents how many people from a
mainstream media video will go to a
partisan left video as you can see
the the line representing the data is
substantially larger
going to the left than the right when
you look at from a partisan right wing
video to the center the line is
comparable from the partisan left to the
center meaning
partisan right gets two-thirds gets
sixty percent of what uh sixty-eight
percent of what the left gets in terms
of views but has an equal amount of
people being recommended away from
partisan right-wing content showing the
left is favored um whether inadvertently
or on purpose on youtube so we can talk
about twitter we can talk about the
stuff and again i will stress to
everybody who's watching or listening
we've had conversations we had allad
aliyahu on and he pulled up pew which
said most people are pro-choice and then
i pulled up gallop which said most
people want restrictions on abortion
you're always going to find some data
and it's and it's hard to know what's
true but everybody has their way there
is an issue i just came up i just found
about this specific study that you're
talking about this is the mark ledwich
right
okay um
basically let me pull up exactly what we
got here okay to examine what youtube's
algorithm recommends to viewers
ledwich and zaitsev went through those
channels videos and scraped each one's
recommendation data so they were able to
see what youtube offered in the up next
box to people watching each video
however lead witch and zaitsev crucially
did this while not logged into a youtube
account because youtube had no
personalization data to go off of
each box of up next recommendations it
served lead witch and saitzev was a
generalized blank slate collection of
videos the algorithm is literally
incapable of introducing an anonymous
logged out user to increasingly radical
content this is from tube filter how
many how many of youtube's viewers are
logged in and have accounts oh we should
check that out too so the issue is this
which i'm talking about has nothing to
do with i mean it's literally the
average person will they be fed left in
a right-wing content and that doesn't
disprove anything i said
so basically nor does it provide any
evidence in the contrary i mean it looks
like if that you're logged in that uh
based on user data and recommendation
data then it does seem like they funnel
to people to more right-wing content
based what's your studies but the study
i brought before what's that well i just
i mentioned it before you know one of
the issues too is we're both we're going
to run into this and i don't think we'll
have an answer for this is
who's doing the study there was a study
that uh
like
will will say something not true about
me or not true about you
if they're trying to get their whatever
outcome they want this is this is the
big challenge with trying to figure out
data in this regards there was a study
that came out that claimed i was like
uh like and cap far right or something
which is just like i don't even know how
they come up with that i mean come on if
someone wants to accuse me of being a
conservative based on modern tribalism
we'll have an argument but
and cap right wing i was just like
so i i can't wait hold on hold on i just
came out because i looked up the uh i
looked up the author of the study mark
ledwich yeah i mean he
he has a um
looks like he's a q a defender
i i don't i don't i don't know i mean it
seems like i i mean i wouldn't trust
someone who believes in a conspiracy
theory like humanon honestly what about
russiagate um yeah what about russiagate
why what does russia get to do with it
what does kiana have to do with what
we're talking about
the author of the study you're sighting
seems to be a q non-believer and and
what about the studies you want to
reference look
if i reference the study that uh
reference the study give me the name
we'll pull up their q and on bs come on
what are you talking about i mean you
write your writes a study you got you
hear the guy's name i don't know you
referenced the study sure if you want me
to told your name
and want me to pull up their twitter
account and find the stupid things
they've posted this is it look
is not just like posting something
stupid q9 is a whole belief set people's
whole world views what is this what did
he defend what did he defend um let's
bring it up right now i'll bring up the
whole long medium blog blog post here
um
let's see we got uh
in the past few months facebook twitter
and youtube have been waging a war
against kunan
um a leviant of a conspiracy theory that
uh explains among other things that
there's a deep state cabal of jewish
satanist globalist democratic elites in
government business and the media
secretly controlling the world and
running a global style check sex
trafficking ring
most recently q9 fans have claimed that
kovid 19 is a hoax and that the u.s
election was rigged against donald trump
social media giants recognizing these
conspiracies were gobbling up a lot of
engagement on their sites took action
and censoring them uh and then he goes
on do you defend them so it doesn't
sound like he believes in it at all he
referred to it as a conspiracy theory
and then he also said well yeah
no no no no no no no wait wait defend
him come on pull that out sure where did
he defend these guys
i don't think he did
well i'm looking through that it's a
long piece yeah he didn't he didn't
defend them
mark ludwig oh here we go here we go q
on believers have already demonstrated
their ability to do this very well
talking about
um basically uh getting content out
there and uh you know um getting their
content out there even when they're
already banned from facebook how is that
defending hold on
uh when they hijack the hashtags save
the children uh save the children and
save our children a fundraiser for
anti-trafficking charity i mean that's
not what those two things were for those
who are saying he's wrong he's wrong
about those were not fundraisers for
anti-trafficking
come on come on what i just you said he
defended and then you read an academic
piece where he talked about them not in
favor of them no no i just told you how
he called the hashtag the
slogans they use online
he called them a fundraiser for
anti-trafficking charity and what and i
think didn't he say they hijacked a
hashtag which was for an
anti-trafficking cherokee like they or
charity like they stole it right they
stole it from them um that's not what i
how i'm reading this but maybe it is let
me read it again
uh
i i it seems he's not a defender of q
and dude i mean i've talked to this guy
he's not even political okay he's like
you talk to him that means something you
you could give a uh that's why i talked
to him because when he did the research
and pulled it up i asked him for
comments and to clarify clarify and and
and that's what we talked about
so
look i i will absolutely concede the
issue is
like i mentioned we had a lot on he's
cool dude and he referenced when it came
to abortion pew research data and i was
like well that conflicts with what i
read and i pull up gallop and gallop had
a different phrasing which was slightly
different and then i was like
you know what man the challenge is
everybody's fighting over politics and
trying to win and you're going to get
researchers who try and argue both sides
so like if i show you a researcher who
says
the left gets favored you're going to be
like what how can that be i've read
research saying otherwise and i'll say
the exact same thing to you
and then ultimately people are trying to
figure out who's telling the truth and
it's it's damn near impossible
so that's that's a reality let's move on
i mean i didn't mention a major flaw
with that study though i mean it is that
is a flaw to god
that was the point i was making though
right so it's not it's not the point you
it's not the point you wanted it to be
but my point was if a regular person
goes on youtube are they going to be fed
in which direction and the data shows
the average person is fed to the left
now if you're talking about logged in
users we need to know how many of the
average person who watches youtube is
logged in it's actually relatively low
but
there's i think you know what a billion
views per month no no it's more than
that it's like 100 billion or something
like that most people aren't logged in
most people don't log in so it's like
when their cookies or whatever are in
there what are they being recommended if
you want to argue that logging in
changes things for sure let's do an
analysis on that maybe that's something
to be seen but what percentage of people
is that relative the average person
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you